Thanks everyone Great to see such a big
audience Just to Raise some hands Who
Knows
Iceberg Who is using
It Still some work to do Here but We Get
to it so My name is foc 3sprong and I'm
open source commit contrib engineer at
Tab  I get paid to do open source
software My Dream Job eh I'm A commit on
Afro Parque de file format
eh Iceberg the table format do it in the
colum store and airflow the
orchestration engine So if you have Any
open prs that you still need  to get in
here you can find my github Handle Ping
Me and I will help you
ehm So This Was Last Week My Daughter
She's tipping her toes Into the Actual
North
Sea also if you have Any questions
please Always Reach Out To Me I'm also
happy to help Around like Iceberg but
Any other Question as well eh If You Go
to the Community link There is a slack
Channel for eh Iceberg and If you have
Any questions
Free to
Reach so what to Expect in this Talk eh
what is Iceberg and Why  do you need it I
think That's the most important part well
dive to the anatomy of an Iceberg table
what are the components And how is a
query Being planned some design
decisions that we took in pi Iceberg The
Python implementation and some examples
of P Iceberg in  the wild including a
demo I think the most important question
Always What is Iceberg I Always Find It
quite difficult Because It's a bit of an
abstract concept It's actually A Table
format It's open Standard Which means
It's fully open It's license It's just
in repository everyone Can  Make changes
to the specifications eh for tables with
Seel Behavior and what This Means is
that at some Point in time when we had
adfs we Said like ok Let's put Like A
bunch of CS files Just
us start reading Them can scale Out we
have no consistency  but it's not a
problem because We Get Like Major
Paris Back in Return for that but that
Yes People really came back to that so we
don't use CSV
anymore Sometimes for convenience but we
went to parquet h Just to have
structured file formats and now  we're
going to The Next Level with table
formats like Iceberg Where we have like
we go back to tables on an object Store
As it is Just Like A regular Sequel
database I think That's
really cool If like a company make
decisions based on data you  want to
consistency in there no
errors founded Is Back in 2018 then It
became open source Before was developed
at Netflix They try to solve like three
Major problems First One is Cost and
Performance Netflix They actually record
Everything So if on Netflix constantly
Being Ab tested If  Go over
ui
of
datam
had be costly because Lot of small files
compression wasal If Talk of dat This is
like Ser Money They One Of The Ace was to be
able to effectively make small files
into bigger files
Toy
per
isow
security
leak
Clean is Dangerous takes Time
ex
table
hard correctness issues
par tables like h tables They Don't Any
guarantees table Reason
can in
there
careful Where does it Fit Layer On Top
Store Cloud
agnostic
currency
conflicting process the same table
detect at the catalog level will handled
byce effing in
there but  if you want to read you can
also omit catalog Partly to your object
Store parce table
I think One Of The Big benefits of
Iceberg is that It's widely adopted
Across The Industry Both for open source
software and also for proprietary
software Like Big Atina and open source
if you want to use like streaming Jobs
then you will Pick big if you want to
do batch etl You Will Go With The Spark
and if you want to do like Analytics on
your box itself then you will go for wb
so That's It's pure
Freedom As  long as implement
specification correctly can Just Read
the Tables
I know This Is The technical conference
Let's Get More Into the technical
details so like I said Iceberg is a
specification and it's constantly being
involved so the first version that is
When It First was like setting Stone
Like This is how we gna design It this
is how the metadata Layer is gna look
like and it was version One version two
eh merge on read was added So if you
have a very big Parque file you want to
say like this record is being deleted
don't want to reite par file you can also
like let par file that
position is deleted that is more
readable It Knows omit specific position
in par
f ex cdc Jobs This Is much More
efficient to f
toes V3 is in the Works that will
include like  default
values
encryption
is easy to add like complexity but Why
do we need It Safety on like I classical
tabl You Could actually wr like data
that was had Like A Different schema to
the
table if you would start reading it you
like a big error
isre
Iceberg  like is in l it's easy to the
end user What This Means is that
especially High Tes In The Past you have
to have Knowledge of like how the table
is Partition to do your query
effectively if you for example would
Forget like the Partition column in your
then you would do like a full table scan
And then your cluster Would Be Red Hot
like for two days and returning Like
Only like a couple of
rows with Ice This is All Being put
Under the hood so you don't have to
worry About It  analyst eh and It Just is
Just
performant It's Safe It's compliant What
is most important Here is Isolation So
if multiple process Right the same table
actually detect like If There is a
conflict and if do the conflict
revolution for you eh support updates
and leads so want  to clean up some pii
data in there you can use this very
Easily with Iceberg object Store native
eh The classical Parque tables h Tables
rfs guarantees ex list operations on
object Store are quite expensive because
paging going
onoo on object Store and also like hases
Which are  not available on object
Stores engine
compatible Lazy just like me I most
Developers make CH to
ofs specification of the table All Lazy
adding new table new data rewriting Any
data then It will do apply the new
schema If add it you will the new not in
data  latest schema
One very important concept of eberg is
that we track the fields by ID SO
instead of for example do colum
rename These ids Are immutable we say
just colum id4 was called idx and now
It's called user ID and is like a
metadata
Operation so Let's  Look at Anatomy so
Every query starts At The Top Where we
have the
catalog There we have
metadata That's All on S3
if the catalog you can go to the
metadata file
the right Side you will see like two
snapshots that to manifest
list to manifest And To  The data files I
know There is Lot of Concepts but Just
Together let's take want to do aery
Where We Like from New York
ceng
People and Pickup date like later than
2023 January
1 bit smaller on the back I think so
This Is How It Looks Like  This is the
the metadata the top Layer D a json
file eh this contains like information
like the schema The Partition Spec the
Sword order
ehm also Iceberg has the concept of
branches and tagging So you can actually
specific Snapshot of the table you can
give it Give  It A Tag or you can go like
Branch from the main Branch do some
change to the table
Tos
to manifest list is a AV
file manifest list I converted The AVRO
to Jason we also Look at
It This Is The manifest lists to the
manifest what we  see Here is already the
partitions this case Upper and lower
Bound dates we can use pring data in
this case we see that the The Upper
Bound Is 2021 as the 07 19 and we're
looking for data from 2023 so in this
case You Could already  Skip like this
Branch of the of the
table in this case you can see like
There are More manifest list but I
collapsed One of
them then we go to the manifest itself
ehm this contains more information So
This has a Link To The to the data file
in this case we Parque file and it is
Partition table by Day in this case see
the the Partition Thursday April
29 so in this case It Doesn't match
predicate so that will be skipped as
well and what it also has is the Meta
information on  the columns themselves Iceberg
Tracks automatically The Upper and the
lower Bound of each of the of the columns
and based on this it can also prune Away
par files that not relevant The
query thise we can Field
low is that relevant The we passengers
lar what we can  see h we have multiple
layers of pruning fewer task and calls
What This Means is
that When data is not relevant for us we
can Just It Away we don't have to
Execute The task and also make much Less
to object Store Which is also reducing
Cost and increasing Performance and as
very important There are no listing
operations so it's not doing Any listing
on certain partitions Just to see like
what kind of files are in there because
Everything Has Like A direct reference
to the file itself Which is speeding it
up so  inad like even if your Parque read
is the fastest skipping It is even
faster
Right so I did a lot of work on P Ice I
just take you to some of the design
decisions That We took there de top we
he The metadata file in json je  he de
AVRO
ehm files H de manifest files and in the
bottom we have the
parquet so pi iber we actually use this
pid dentic library to read The json
files Which Works very well
ehm mostly because like I said we have
Different versions of the of the  the
Men
manifest the metadata I keep confusing
Them the men
metadata The version One version two
ptic we can ok if it's discriminator
value verse
One as
This And what we do as is using ptic we
version One we upgrade to version so We
Don't  to make Any distinction the rest
of code we assum is vers is very
nice
AV we have a new implementation in 0.5
Yes the Python AV was quite slow we had to
go to we 20
Speed ​​we implemented Our
[Music]
owns like B quite Simple had  schema
files reader decer
is
Yes tricky
stuff in Standard AVRO a map with
integer Key is not
allow Maps have to have the string Key
Which is not really convenient for
Iceberg in this case Because We have Lot
of references based on the on the Field
ID Which  is integer but actually can get
Around It If You Write it as a list of
struct integer binary how is enc AV is
that you like the Number of Elements
Just Like integer then you pawise like
the key
you can Just encode It const by Only
strink is  Only imp on Yes on on the
specification level of AVRO but There's
No technical Reason to not do this so
It's fully binary compatible You Could
even read it with Like A rec avo
reader erm yes for the Parque reader Yes
we Didn't implement It because  There
many very Excellent Parque readers Out
There I don't think It Makes Sense to
faster let do
demo
So This How Looks in this case we inst
low
catalog Run
lo All available
online
races New York
cace taes in New York
cace
Tax
scheme is the  New York City txi dataset
and if we Look at the Partition Spec
then we can see the table is Partition
by Day this called the dat transform and
this reference to Field number two Which
is this case This one ehm So if you
insert data if you read  data It
automatically Knows like How to find the
partitioning Because if you filter on on
this Field It Knows that it can use this
partitioning to speed of the
query I create like a requ to polars
that
is we What's going on
H we f metadata
j Next  we do is Go snot
manif
First manifest file
itself because here you can see the
predicate we Select one day of data we
can see that we Take One manifest And
then we read like the Actual paret data
and here is the same Here We Do a Head
On The on the file see if it exists then
we do a Negative scan of 46 bytes Get
Like The footer From The pet file And
then we Get Like The pet file itself
Which is 1.8 meg And then The Returns
like 120 die G
rows If We  Just collect
Everything h then we can see that There
is Lot of Io going on because Now It
fetes Like all the files That are
available in the
dataset so Here we can see the pruning
eh
working
as another project I'm working on is
integration  with airflow is an open
source Kafka Connect to Iceberg table
where can actually offload like the
Kafka stream into Iceberg table directly
cdc What does it sets Like A property on
the Iceberg table That's called vtts
Fell through Tim property and this will
actually Tell You What the  minimum is of
the partitions in the Kafka eh
topic Partition can Different Point and
in airflow you would like to know like
ok I'm A certain Point In Time then
start processing The data example I
passed an hour and I'm sure that all the
data is in there Pass the day sure that
all the data from Yesterday is in there
and you can use this very nicely h this
this timestamp to actually Block an
airflow Until this This Time Has Been
passed Until your cka Connect
stream
You Want to try it  yourself This Is The
Link To The The do Spark Iceberg That's
also part of this
Presentation want to get your hands
Dirty on the coat Free to go
There Iceberg If want to go Right Away
can Just install It
Pip Just Looking Ahead 0.5 is in flight
released  Now brings new gcs AGS running
lambda lot Of Performance improv
especially on the af and reduced I and
we mov to ptic 2.0 Which was quite
because They moved from inheritance
based to like attribute based Which Ja
was quite a process and we're also
working on  the 0.6 release Which will
also Bring writing wr support from
Python so then you can actually Just
write your data directly from Python
into Ice
table
This Is Just the tip of the
Iceberg It's just like introduction Into
the Iceberg structure also The query
planning There's a lot  of extra stuff in
there ex
del mer we also Lot of Logic in there
Just to make that we pull in the
relevant to nice and Fast Puff
indies Low
Next the
table Bloom filters
Hyper time travel and branching that I
also
touched
bri That's It
me ne